the thing I get asked a
lot will Stargate be woke when it
returns let's have a chat about it
welcome to sidere your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie
[Music]
Channel if you're a regular Sid tracker
you'll know I'm not the biggest fan of
the ter woke
I kind of hate it I'm not one of those
people that go it doesn't happen there
are filmmakers that produce propaganda
there are filmmakers that hi Harry um
there are
filmmakers that um put their own
thoughts opinions agendas ahead of the
story and that's the only real problem I
have really when things get a bit woke
is when an agenda or that propaganda
gets ahead of the storyline that the
people are trying to tell and it does
happen the only thing I would argue is
that it always happened there's always
been propaganda TV shows there's always
been this sort of thing but how many
decades did we have like very cold war
propaganda in our movies TV Etc TV has
always been and movies kind of racist
kind of sexist kind of other things
depending on the culture at the time and
how it was then projected through our
media you know so you know you can't
watch a lot of 1970s TV shows and think
oh God this is quite
misogynistic um it's it's culture and
Society has changed it's adapted
since we though since the me too
movement have had a little bit of a
problem with some media and some TV
shows and I do think it's gotten a bit
out of hand and has made a lot of people
angry and start cheatting woke at
things let's just remember quickly that
the word woke actually means awake to
like Prejudice Etc in our society it's
supposed to be a good thing but anyway
it's been corrupted a little bit by some
people that have made it into a negative
thing but to be fair it is a negative
thing when it overtakes your gender and
blah blah blah like I just
said
so will the new Stargate series or
anything else at MGM planning to do in
the next couple of years like the
RoboCop reboot of the franchise B
woke since the me to movement and this
is a thought I started a second ago so
excuse my editing but since the me to
movement Executives have been absolutely
terrified by the prospect of being
called racist sexist anything
elist and I think that's been very
evident in a lot of movies lot of TV
series and things I mean you could even
say the Marvels thing in um endgame when
um all the Marvel women appeared and
they sort of did that dramatic we're all
women ra if I was a woman I would have
found that really patronizing by the way
but anyway they did that at least in
part I think because the executives were
going there's a lot of willies running
around there's not a lot of women can we
have a little less of a Fest and
have a little bit more of you know
actual the women standing up and
fighting as well so that is really a
response to them being called sexist you
only had black widow children and even
she was a sex figure really initially
you know Scarlet Johansson in the first
film yeah okay she could kickass but she
was really there just to uh get Robert
Dan jun's attention Iron Man was like
hello hello black widow how are you um
so you know even that now Marvel has
become a lot more balanced over the last
few years but there still is the truth
that the most popular characters in
Marvel in DC as well it's not just
marvel are
men so there's been an attempt and I
think an
overcorrection by Studios Etc to try to
balance this out we've been sexist and
we've been racist for about 100 years
guys let's go completely the other way
and that has pissed off a lot of people
because it overtakes the
story so is MGM going to still continue
to make that over correction well no
because there's now one thing that the
studios are almost as scared of being
called they're scared of being called
sexist they're scared of being called
racist they're also now scared of being
called woke and we've started to see
that in a lot of TV shows I keep telling
you guys how I just saw the Tulsa King
who Sylvester slone in it and it's
brilliant it's fantastic but there is a
scene in there I think it's the third or
fourth episode which did stand out like
a saw Thum the character the Tulsa King
play byone has just got out of prison
and he's talking about how he doesn't
understand people are always on their
phones and he has to you know he can't
tell a girl she looks pretty and he's
he's basically complaining about the
Millennials but does mention things sort
of being woke it was very much the
producers the writers even the actor I
think I think came lot from still slow
and learn a little bit about his
politics basically saying this show
won't be woke so don't worry about it
you're going to enjoy this show this
show this is for Middle America this
show is for men and women that you know
don't want to see too much politics in
their TV
and it was very very good now I don't
need a TV show to tell me it's not going
to be woke I just need it to you know
have a story I want TV shows and writers
to have agendas I want them to have and
to be able to tell us about the things
that they think are important if a
writer feels that there is racial
Prejudice and he wants to say something
about it then great and in the genre I
love the most science fiction that can
be done through metaphor
and stories at the end of the day
obvious every Android ever in every
sci-fi book ever is really about slavery
or Prejudice or lacking freedom in some
way the Android is really the perfect
way to tell a story about slavery
without actually having to do a big
serious movie about slavery so the
studios are now afraid to be called
woke I think actually She-Hulk when they
tried to poke fun at woke and they
basically did it several eight times
throughout the series and the social
media reaction to that was dramatic it
went down like a lead balloon oh my arms
started to hurt I really felt this was
an attempt by the studio to put the woke
people and the people that shout woke in
their place they were pointing the
finger to them saying you're a bunch of
morons basically and we're going to
laugh at you the problem with the
attempt was it failed badly it riled up
the people that shout woke even more and
actually the people that don't shout
woke sort of started thinking hm maybe
the studios are the ones maybe those
people have actually got a point it
backfired
massively and I don't think we'll see
that again in any major TV show or
series at the end of the day whether
Stargate is criticized as being woke or
not will come down to the Creator at the
moment we still strongly believe that is
going to be the guys that brought us the
expanse it's going to be Hawk HBY and
Mark
Fergus I don't see anything in their
IMDb that suggests that they are going
to come at this with anything other than
an attempt to make a really brilliant
Stargate series and I don't see anything
in their IMDb and their history of work
that suggests they really have an
opinion or an agenda that is going to
overshadow the show the executives
though still will put pressure on them
to fill certain demographics certain
rules certain things that they want the
show to say is Amazon the cyer studio
that will do that generally no generally
they pick people to run the show and
those people then run it I'm told Amazon
are very much a business the bosses at
the top really don't get involved now
that can be a really good thing
sometimes because you get shows like the
boys which is just allowed to get on
with it it can also be a bad thing
sometimes if you've not got the right
people in control rings of power so this
is my very long winded way of
saying I don't think Stargate is going
to end up being woke it's going to
matter who ends up running it of course
but I think the Studios have had a
couple of years where they've panicked I
think that time is now passed I think if
anything they'll end up going the other
way particularly with the success of
shows like Yellowstone which really
really ain't
woke I think the executives have
realized that yes they need to not be
sexist they need to not be racist but
they also don't have to massively
overcorrect and go completely the other
way either that we are grown-ups and we
can have a little bit of balance in our
TV so will Stargate be
woke no we'll be all right people and
anyway way let's not start accusing it
of of being woke until the damn Show's
at least been announced eh but guys get
into the comments and tell me what you
think is TV sort of getting back to
normal after a massive overcorrection
and you know Executives panicking do you
see a change in the last couple of years
maybe with a lot of the television going
back to what we may be used to and do
you agree with me though that TV shows
will always have propaganda they will
always have agendas and that's not
necessarily A Bad Thing get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
premere first and you get to see them
without the adverts you even get a free
gift you're welcome also go to sidet
trek. co.uk where I do articles based on
a lot of our videos and we try to add a
little bit more information for you to
digest
so go and check it out I now going to go
and take my dog and have a lovely walk
on the beach see you next time
[Music]
guys